ladies and gentlemen senator boxer
senator would want to start we're gonna
get a lot of questions from the audience
Martha and I will follow up throughout
let's start by getting right to our
audience my new Tevas fell apart on a
hike and I only got a store credit what
the hell I think that's a disgrace hey
man how can I get a ride back to my
apartment we got some mom's here could
you settle a bet I have with my buddy
Renzo who would win in a fight between
Freddy Krueger and the Democrats you
know what Democrats are gonna lose I
knew in your face friends oh you owe me
a babe cartridge I just want to tell you
how much I loved your book bro I had no
idea there were so many kinds of cold
the best seller sold all over the world
and we made money yeah
why are my parents such dicks about
paying rent and not playing with the
cat's nipples when people are giving up
on life that's what happens it feels
like I'm the only black guy here
[Applause]
and that is why I believe we should make
public colleges and universities
tuition-free
[Applause]